so I'm going to thank god you're hurt
Tyler hurt I found a
for supporting this program this is a
research program it's one that brings
students from all across the country and
some of them from abroad from a whole
range of different disciplines to come
together in New York and do
collaborative historical research
research that's historical in nature but
it's also meant to address emerging and
future problems this summer it's on
global health and pandemic threats last
year we worked on nuclear proliferation
and in coming years we'll be looking at
religious violence apocalyptic movements
and also climate change and
international security so that's the
Hertzog program and Thank You Roger
Hertog for making that possible thank
you to this summer to the Center for the
history and ethics of public health at
the Melman School for co-sponsoring this
lecture series and the communication
department at the Melman school for
making available these refreshments so
thank you all but more importantly let
me thank Donald Henderson he is a
distinguished scholar at the Center for
biosecurity of the University of
Pittsburgh Medical Center he was also a
founder of that Center they're bringing
more chairs
fascinating isn't it yeah so so let me
just mention a few things about da
Henderson my my colleague my co teacher
Steve Morris introduced him earlier
today to our students in the program and
he said and it's true how do you
introduce somebody who led the worldwide
campaign to eradicate one of the world's
greatest cures smallpox it's very hard
but let me this point out how he's had
already three careers at least first of
all he started out as a chief of the
surveillance section of the Union ology
branch the Centers for Disease Control
he went on from there at the age of 38
to head up the w-h-o program that
succeeded after some 10 years in
eradicating smallpox all over the world
he went on to be Dean of the faculty at
Johns Hopkins School of Public Health I
won't say anything more about the Johns
Hopkins School since I know we have a
number of people here from the melmans
school but needless to say it gives us
very great and very serious competition
and so from there he went on and had a
whole nother career in helping this
country in the world prepare for the
threat of bio terrorism he helped to
lead not just in the founding of the
center first at Johns Hopkins and then
at the with the University of Pittsburgh
but then he went on from there for a
number of important positions in in
Washington ending with his directorship
of the office of public health emergency
preparedness when that office was first
created and quickly had a three billion
dollar budget to deal with were just a
few years earlier he'd had trouble
scraping together a foundation support
for the Center in Baltimore and then
finally as the principal science advisor
in the office of the Secretary of the
Department of Health and Human Services
but he's come to us tonight to talk
about smallpox the death of a disease I
should mention he may be himself shy and
mentioning the fact that it I think
comes out of a really tremendous book
with the same title I found the book
fascinating I'm sure many of you will as
well and I think as memoirs go
especially by somebody who has had
already such an amazing career three
different careers it's remarkably
insightful and open I think in in
acknowledging the great ironies in some
cases tragic ironies of the many careers
that he's had the one thing that we all
know him for of course is in eradicating
smallpox for all of us but then to to
later in his career have to once again
confront this terrible scourge at least
as the potential of reemerging as a
terrible scourge in the form of
bioterrorism it really is an epic story
and so he tells it incredibly well in
that book but he's going to tell us
tonight about some aspects of it in his
his lecture so I want to thank him again
for coming and thank you all for
attending
let me say it's a great pleasure for me
to be here and with the the mailman's
School of Public Health has been a
particularly a particular interest of
mine because Alan Rosenberg was a very
dear friend and somebody whom I had an
enormous respect for and as Dean's at
schools of Public Health and they get
together against that what they talk
about all the problems they have and it
sounds like we Hopkins and mailman
School of Public Health have both
opportunities and problems that are very
similar and a real challenge in public
health at this point but let me say two
I'm especially glad to be here with
Steve Morris who's we've been together
off and on and early days when somehow
other the fret of a bioterrorism was not
taken very seriously by many people and
also the new and emerging infections
idea that we had a threat potential from
agents coming into the country and
really that it was something to be taken
seriously and we really ought to be
working with other countries and other
laboratories far more closely than we
are and we ought to be learning a good
deal more about and doing research on a
lot of the diseases which many regard as
exotic diseases but we must remember
aids came in 82 and whereas it today
this is just one of many diseases that
are becoming part of have become part of
the world scene rather than isolated in
some remote area but today to talk about
smallpox which I'm sure none of you have
seen a case and I think I encounter many
people they think of it as well I guess
it was one of those diseases with a rash
and probably occurred in the tropics and
I don't know in fact many people that I
suppose there's a little bit still left
somewhere
I don't know but it really passed from
recognition because it the last case
occurred 34 years ago and it's
understandable but that this seems like
something that's ancient history
too many of us though it is still very
much contemporary history and it was
1980 that the World Health Assembly met
reviewed all the material and the report
of a special committee and declared that
the world and all its peoples have won
freedom from smallpox and recommended
that vaccinations be discontinued
everywhere it was a remarkable event in
the last year we've had a number of
celebrations culminating with a large
statue outside of w-h-o of a vaccinator
commemorating the last of smallpox this
was the way it was announced in the
magazine of the World Health
Organization which seemed to get the
point very specifically and to put this
into perspective the from the Lasker
foundation is award to w-h-o and as they
say smallpox mankind's most feared and
devastating infection has frequently
changed the course of history itself and
indeed it has again and again Richard
Preston the author who's written several
books including demon in the freezer
called it that this may well have been
the greatest life-saving achievement in
the history of Medicine and finally the
Secretary of Health tommy Thompson said
that the campaign is a testament to the
difference the global health community
can make when it truly comes together
for a common purpose and it truly did
and in fact through some of the darkest
days of the Cold War we were working
very closely with the Russians
were very helpful in many many ways but
to put this into context of history this
is a disease which we know goes back as
far as the Pharaohs 3,500 years ago
because there are mummies for to be
exact which have lesions you can see
them pretty evident on the on the under
the neck and they clearly died of
smallpox and so we have indication if
they go back at least 3,500 years and
throughout history it has been a
pestilence well beyond anything that you
can imagine it's certainly far worse
than plague or any of the other diseases
that you could mention it has been a
killer it is the only disease which is
represented by specific deities and this
is true and there are deities in Japan
from China literature and Japan in China
in India in West Africa it's the only
disease for which there are specific
deities and in India extensive numbers
of Sita Mata temples and I think this is
an indication that the peoples
throughout the ages have regarded this
as one of the great problems as no other
disease but even until unfairly recently
it was more of a problem and we might
imagine
first of all we'll go back and in the
20th century we a conservatively
estimate there were 300 million deaths
due to smallpox and the New York Times
came up with a metric in comparison
saying do you know that there were 120
million people died either directly or
indirectly as the k-t cause of armed
conflict in the 20th century in other
words 120 million due to armed conflict
300 million to smallpox so this is a
disease of great mad
- when we began in 1967 with the global
eradication program the closest we can
come is that of about ten million cases
and two million deaths that year that
year was reported from 43 countries and
many people don't realize that we
required vaccination in this country of
all school children up until 1972 and
that was 23 years after the last case in
this country so great was the fear of
smallpox coming in being introduced and
spread that we were continuing
vaccination as were other countries
continuing vaccination for a disease
they did not have simply because of the
fear of smallpox so let me say a word
about the disease itself it's a virus it
spreads from only during the rash man is
the only host so there are no animal
vectors on this no animal infections in
fact this has been a problem in research
because we have no experimental animal
that we can infect with smallpox and as
you think about it this means that one
individual has to infect another
individual has to keep another
individual what's going to keep going so
we we we pictured and talked about it as
a chain of infection that had to keep
going constantly and if you could break
the chain
you obviously prevented many cases so
the death rate for smallpox runs about
30% the cases there are no sub clinical
cases that is to say if somebody
infected with a virus we have a rash and
so it's very different from many other
diseases where there are some clinical
cases but for those who survive there
permanently immune for life so that one
attack is all that anybody
so with this disease we had something
which was really quite unique and very
essential and that is we had a vaccine
developed originally in 1796 by an
English country physician named Edward
Jenner who discovered as lore of the
play at time was that milkmaids
did not develop smallpox in milkmaids
they praised their complexion if you
remember from many of the stories it
praised the complexion of the milkmaids
it wasn't because they were drinking
milk it was because they had cow pox
they were prevented from getting
smallpox and so many of the women of the
period were scarred seriously scarred
with smallpox and that it was a real
problem so here's this disease that
vaccine which has been done first in
1796 and there's been vaccination going
through history all the way up until the
present using a strain of cow pox which
is a cousin of smallpox is not not
derived from smallpox it's a totally
separate virus now let's just take a
look at a case I don't that doesn't show
up very well because of the light but if
that's all right you can see here there
are just
boy who recovered from this but what is
it what he would have had would have
been two days a very high fever really
miserable many children had febrile
convulsions with this and then this
would be the third day of this rash
which is now developing we'll go on and
we'll see the rash the vesicles are
becoming pustular pustular a rash and we
feel at this time it would take an
individual about the fifth day that if
you saw it in the emergency room you
wouldn't see you saw this child you
would say it could be any of a number of
different diseases but if you saw this
you would certainly have second thoughts
about this is this smallpox so that's
day five you can see he's miserable and
he has the lesions are on inside of it
mouth and on the tongue
so as trouble drinking is trouble eating
it's really a very bad disease this is
day seven as the pustules grow day nine
you can see it going on and then day
thirteen scabs are now forming over the
pustules of festivals or just did not
does not be scraped off but they're just
resorbing and as you can see looks a
good deal happier than he did at the
earlier days now he he recovered this is
what we'd call a little more severe case
this is an english engineer who came
back into AI got infected in Pakistan
came back and developed the smallpox and
you can see these round lesions that are
on the chest and this is the man that's
the same man on recovery and you can see
when they talk about scarring you can
see how prominent this is now with the
scarring also came cases in a number of
a quite a number of cases of blindness
so in fact this was a leading cause
blindness in India up until 1975 and
similarly in Europe in the 18th and 19th
century so what is eradication and what
what why at this time well we can go
back and there were many there were
several efforts at eradication the first
was awkward which was funded by the
Rockefeller found a cappella before the
foundation and the idea was to treat
patient sick with the disease and
provided to pit privies and encouraged
the truth be warned and after some 14
years they went back to see what had
they been accomplishing and they found
that there was less infection but it was
still continuing to spread you couldn't
stop it yellow fever followed in 1915
and the discovery that you could simply
control mosquitoes ladies a gyp time
mosquitoes which will transmit it if you
could control it in the major population
centers that it would die out in the
periphery because it mosquito has very
much with a lives very close to man but
began that and again it was Rockefeller
sponsoring this and they did quite well
and up until 1932 and then they
discovered and with the most of Latin
America Latin America was free of yellow
fever then they discovered that there
were cases occurring and that there was
a jungle yellow fever
carried by monkeys and that it could
come back to man and so that was the end
of that one malaria followed in 1955 DDT
had been discovered during the War of
the tremendously effective insecticide
and the idea was to spray the walls of a
house mosquito bites the individual
becomes infected flies to the wall to
rest and is killed by the DDT so he the
mosquito does not spread it and this was
very
in a number of areas but it soon became
apparent one that the the insecticide
where they're becoming resistant and
mosquitoes becoming resistant and the
parasite was becoming resistant to some
of the drugs and it was a lot more
expensive than they'd ever imagined and
so after two billion dollars was
expended and when you say 2 billion
that's when 2 billion dollars was really
serious money and at that point it began
to fade and 1973 it finally came to a
halt
well 1967 the smallpox got got under way
and that was a decision of the World
Health Assembly to begin this program
and you can see it it was at the time
malaria eradication was failing and so
there was not there's a lot of concern
about going ahead with smallpox
eradication now sake and say a little
more about it more than later guinea
worm infection a worms that you see
pictures in the National Geographic of
worms coming out and people wrapping
them up on a stick that's the guinea
worm and it's tropical Africa now only
but they began an eradication program in
66 or 86 and it's now 24 years it was
supposed to be over hopefully in 14
years and it's still going and
unfortunately most of this is in
southern Sudan where all the fighting is
now beginning and breaking out and it's
been a real problem and then polio which
now is in its 23rd year and where
there's still polio in for endemic
countries and about three others are
seriously reinfected about 1 billion
dollars per year is now being expended
just on polio eradication and there is
hope now that Gates Foundation's got
very much involved and hoped that the
end of 2012 that the last case is
will occur but there have been
disappointments again and again and
again so I won't go into that but it's
polio is still with us so those are the
seven eradication programs the way
smallpox came about was in 1959 the
Soviet Union had come back to the United
Nations they'd withdrawn all
representation in the UN because of the
Korean War that was going on over with
are we right in the Korean War yes and
so they'd withdrawn and for nearly a
decade they were out thank you this as
they just came back and the delegates
wanted to be supportive and say fine
let's all get together and we agree and
so began a program in 1959 which was not
done very seriously and there was a
budget of $100,000 per year and they had
a staff of five people and you can
imagine not a lot was getting
accomplished and there were only five
staff members at that time so the Soviet
Union was really very unhappy about this
the US was supporting malaria
eradication putting a lot of money into
it the Soviets over here were supporting
smallpox of malaria smallpox eradication
and they were providing a lot in the way
of vaccine and and trying to do things
but they every year they were saying to
the Director General and to the assembly
we really must do more
why are you playing favorites and with
the Americans and the malaria program
you should be supporting more the Soviet
Sepang sir
Soviet support and smallpox program so
at this point the Director General was
very frustrated w-h-o did not have a lot
of money and he decided that they would
put together he a program a plan
10 year plan and this director general
plan to support a to introduce it to the
assembly and then see what they would do
and he was confident that they would
vote it down because it cost a lot more
money and a plan the strategy was unique
at that time there were a number of
small pox programs going on were people
trying to vaccinate quite a few because
it was such a problem disease that most
countries had to have some sort of a
program and the goals that were set was
to vaccinate 80% of the population and
the key thing that was unique was the
second component of it was to say we
should have a beginning at the beginning
of the program we want to report from
every health center as whether they got
smallpox or they don't and made
provision and for teams to go out and
try to stop the outbreaks while they
went ahead with a routine vaccination
try to find the cases stop the outbreaks
and this was important because the
question was where is smallpox where are
the real problem areas who is getting
the disease it's just made sense to be
studying a disease to find out it's
character pathological characteristics
so that you can tailor your program and
a number of things came from that which
were surprises to us one we found out it
didn't spread half as fast as everybody
said it did it spread like wildfire well
it didn't spread all that fast because
you remember it only spreads
person-to-person and the individuals
usually got so sick and by the end of
the second day by the time the rash
begins they're in bed and that spreads
to contacts immediately but you don't
have people in schools you don't have
people in workplaces but didn't spread
rapidly and I can go on there were a
number of things that we found as we
into the surveillance program but those
are the two components of the program
the two major pieces the
director-general felt that the w-h-o
could it should support this the extent
of 2.4 million dollars a year well that
sounds like not very much and in fact it
really wasn't all that very much I tell
you the truth but their whole budget was
only about 55 million dollars at that
time so 2.4 million on top of us was
going to be quite an expenditure the
delegates objected there a number of
people said we tried to eradicate
malaria and it can't be done so why do
you think you can do this we can't have
another failure and the many of them
including the US and major donors said
contributors to World Health
Organization said we don't want to spend
more money in the international
organizations and that was a philosophy
at that time and WH OHS budget is made
up of a certain amount of money every
country has to contribute a certain
amount as based on their GDP and so that
the u.s. paid at that time was paying
between 25 and 30 percent of the budget
that I recall and so the big donors said
we don't want to put more money into
this and so that was a group that was
objecting the Director General was
opposed to it because he didn't think it
could be done and he certainly didn't
want another as he saw it another
albatross around his neck he's already
got the malaria bit so he was opposed to
it but they took a boat and it had to
have 58 votes to approve and 60 voted
for it so it barely made it it was
within two votes of not going ahead so
he blamed the u.s. as having been
supportive as they hadn't been before
they'd been mainly focusing malaria but
in this occasion they did join in in
saying we really ought to get rid of
small
box they voted against the budget by the
way later on but that's another story
but they the director-general felt it
was the us that was getting w-h-o into
this terrible position so he wanted an
American there and quite candidly so
when it goes down the tube fails the US
will be seen to be holding the bag on us
so long with WHL and it will not blame
w-h-o so much so I was working in the
Centers for Disease Control working in
the small pox area I was working at a
number of diseases that we had under
surveillance and I was chief of the
surveillance section at that time and
one of them was smallpox and I could it
was for good reason at the time we were
doing some studies so he decided he
wanted me as director of the program and
I got called the office of the Surgeon
General and they said he said you're
going to go to Geneva as head of the
program and I said well I'm Public
Health Service and we don't do this in
the Public Health Service not like the
Army Navy Air Force they you know assign
people and move them around like health
service we discuss it with career
options and future and so forth there
was this is your career option and I
said what suppose I decline and he said
you resign and I got the impression he
was serious so at that point I picked up
and went off to Geneva for 18 months so
the agreement was it would only be for
18 months and that if I sent a cable
back just to say now he would extra
extricate me and have me brought back so
with three kids and a wife we left half
of our household goods in storage
expecting we'd see them very shortly and
it was 11 years later that we unpacked
and you can't imagine what was in that
well the reasons to be concerned because
you look at we we felt we had to have
programs in at least 50 countries and
you add it up and you've got two and a
half million dollars it's $50,000 per
country but it wasn't enough to buy the
vaccine we could not buy the vaccine
with the the amount of money that was
being appropriated from WHL it was hoped
that others would donate but the record
of their contributions from the
industrialized countries and others
voluntary contributions was very poor it
provided for headquarters staff which
was 10 on 10 people for medical officers
to actually five medical officers a to
administrative officers and three
secretaries and that was the total staff
we ever had the whole staff never got to
be larger than 10 and you can bet you
that this was a time when you didn't
have internet we didn't have twit
tweeter
we didn't have Facebook we didn't have
we couldn't even use telex it was too
expensive
you couldn't telephone to most of these
places because it really even the
communication of the capital cities was
terrible so mostly what you had to do
was basically this was travel and by
mail and this is a very it was a
challenge let's just put it that way
we also had the problem that you had
every country is sovereign so they can
decide whether they really want to
participate or not never mind what they
voted in the World Health Assembly think
it very jolly well do it or not do it
and we had some countries that decided
they weren't interested in going ahead
with it so we had that as a problem and
whu-oh actually has six regional offices
each regional officer chief of each
regional office is selected by the
countries of that region and it's it
just as really does not function very
well as a w-h-o and
the director-general like top 10 Mahler
said to me what we really have is an
association of regional offices so that
of the these four regions that we had to
work we really had lukewarm support for
one and total objections by two and one
who would go along so we had from the
regional offices very little help and I
really was not to an inspired to think
we were gonna be getting very far it was
really looked like a hill
fortunately the problems appeared and
kind of one by one and we'd solve a
problem and then another big one who
come if they'd known at the beginning we
had all known about the all that we
would encounter I'm not sure we would
have had the courage to go on but just
one by one they got sorted out 1967 this
was the situation the red countries are
those where it was endemic that is
constantly spreading the blue countries
were those which were thought to be free
and we're having smallpox introduced now
in Latin American you see that's Brazil
is infected but only Argentina had some
importation now what had happened was
that there was a vaccine a method to
produce the smallpox vaccine called
freeze drying on the commercial scale
which had been developed in the UK in
the late 1950s and they introduced it
for a couple of countries and the in the
Americas they had several laboratories
using this freeze-dried vaccine well it
made a difference because this vaccine
could be kept at 98 degrees Fahrenheit
37 degrees centigrade for a month and it
was potent at the end of that time so
little problems that vaccinators going
into the field whereas the old vaccine a
lick
preparation it was 2 to 3 days is all
you had and then the vaccine was no good
well that had been introduced to bid
into Latin America and that was being
more effective than anybody believed or
realized at the time because the
reporting was so bad we really didn't
have a very good idea till the second or
third year really what was going on
Africa south of this era actually all of
those countries were really infected we
just didn't know it at the time and then
you have the India Pakistan Bangladesh
group and then the islands off to the
right which are Indonesia the real
problem was how do we get enough of this
vaccine and so we decided to do
something which we were told we couldn't
do we had to have some quality control
now each of these countries making their
own vaccine I think we had something
like 74 different laboratories making
vaccine you can imagine what some of
this was so we decided our own that we
would just not offer w-h-o assistance to
any Leopard in any country that was not
had a vaccine that would not meet
international standards so we we weren't
saying what your standards what your
vaccine should be or had to be but we
weren't going to get provides support if
you didn't have good vaccine and it was
amazingly effective even though this was
something that we were told we whu-oh
does not monitor and licensed vaccines
that was for sure well we weren't but we
were just making sure we had good
vaccine in the field so we managed to
two countries Canada and Netherlands
offered to test the vaccines that were
there and so we got the vaccines were
being set in and we found that less than
10 percent of the vaccines met any
international standards so most of these
people were vaccinating some of them
weren't vaccinating with no more than
water but they were still putting it
into vials and sending it around so we
had to develop an ash
capacity and what we did was bring
together the heads of laboratories from
five different countries sat them down
for two weeks and worked out a manual
which was simple enough we said so I
could understand it she could make
vaccine and they did this a very good
manual and then they went out from the
different laboratories in one Soviet
Union Netherlands US Canada and Britain
and they were the directors of those lab
went to develop developing countries
labs works with them to get them started
and worked and eventually by six years
we had more than 80% of the vaccine was
produced in the developing countries so
our target for coverage was 80% and here
again we had what we felt was important
was to get quality control and this was
something we had a very difficult time
persuading ministers of health that this
was a good idea and the idea we had was
simply to have a team or teams that
would go after the vaccinators had gone
through and when you vaccinate you're
putting a little drop of vaccine here
you're scratching through it or putting
it in on talked about that then you get
a pustule it comes up and a scab and
then it falls off so you've got evidence
of vaccination so weak team coming
through a week two weeks later could see
who really got vaccinated and so the
idea of having a team that did nothing
no vaccinating but simply as checking on
the work of others was objected to I
would say just about by every ministry
we encountered why aren't these people
vaccinating and not just checking on
what somebody else is doing but this
made a huge difference then it was that
tried to find a faster better method for
injection and we tried the jet injector
gun I won't go into that but it worked
very well when it worked he could
vaccinate a thousand people an hour
their trouble was that broke down so
often that it just wouldn't we had to
give it up the great invention was the
bifurcated needle and this was regarded
as a tremendous breakthrough it was big
enough to break through so that the city
of Philadelphia gives a prize every year
for the outstanding invention of the
year and they've done this since
seventeen something or other
so it's Marconi and Edison and so forth
and so on have been awarded this and the
man who developed the bifurcated needle
received the James Scott prize and he
said this is the least important thing I
ever invented well I'll show you what he
did at that's the neat alliance it's so
long and all it is is got two points on
it and the idea that he had was that
you've got vaccine and it's a liquid and
you dip it in and just enough virus has
held their vaccine to for vaccinating
and at the time the US was doing
vaccination sort of by pressing the
vaccine into the skin but you were
taught very carefully not to break the
skin not to get blood because it washed
the virus out so people were being very
careful and not getting it implanted in
the skin so we had many failures but we
decided well let's take the needle and
suppose we do this and just have them do
a number what we call multiple punctures
and it's very sharp and very very
painless really when you do when you do
this very quickly and we got a second
effect only a hundred percent coverage
takes they were just every vaccination
was working so it had a huge effect
because the amount of vaccine requires
only a quarter as much as what we'd had
with the other ones the training time
was 15 minutes for a villager you could
sterilize it put in a bucket going to be
ready for the next day
it costs us $5.00 per thousand it was
suitable for our budget so this was a
surveillance plan which I were already
talked about and we were finding that
the about the back suit of the disease
spreading like wildfire and it also the
feeling you had to agree vaccinate every
three to five years and we soon found
that vaccination was probably good for
at least 10 years and probably longer so
any plans to revaccinated amad that
point and that made a big difference
the women and purdah could not be
vaccinated in in Pakistan Afghanistan
and we sat down with the village leaders
and talked this over and they agreed
finally that the woman could be
vaccinated in the back of the hand and
so they were being accepting
vaccinations and once they accepted it
they could accept it for the children we
got very good coverage a smallpox
vaccination in Afghanistan in the
management of the program I thought
there were a couple of things that are
important and I think they were
important in the global health that this
is a program that had to be adapted to
the country and what they were doing in
the malaria program was a rigid set of
precepts - what to do when to do it this
we adapted them the idea of this all the
staff being in the field one-third of
the time and that was for a headquarter
staff - so I spent more than actually a
third of the time not just at the
headquarters but going into the field
talking with a vaccine getting an idea
of what's really going through what's
getting through and in the course of
this learning a very great deal we
insisted on that for all the staff and
then sending out reports regularly so
every two three weeks some places more
often sent out reports what's going on
Brazil started a program to put out a
report weekly and that is now their
national infectious disease surveillance
bulletin that is
true in a number of countries this was
kind of the beginning and basically I'd
say the the bit of red tape is
inevitable and people talk about it all
the time I was talking with some of you
and the group but there a couple of
things you learn when you're not sure
whether something should or shouldn't be
done its best thing to do is do it and
ask the question later not as a
hypothetical and then when you're
finally found out and not a good thing
to do don't argue with them we just
learned that Mayor Koch may have caught
ball never do it again you probably only
had to do it once to get that but that's
alright so that there's a hints for the
field that as people learned was very
good 67 that's just the where we--where
69 there's one change significant change
and this was a program that we set up at
CDC just before I left AI D decided to
come forward to support a program in
West Africa 20 countries and so we'd set
it up and we were we were just
dumbfounded here we are three years
later and these countries among the
poorest in the world said smallpox rates
were among the highest and here we were
three years later we're virtually free
well you can imagine we were elated it
was we could see this we didn't need ten
years to get this done this is a this
canoe surveillance containment is gonna
make a big difference by 1973 you can
see all of South America's free
Indonesia is free the only countries in
Africa are Botswana but those are the
last few cases they had Ethiopia and
just India Pakistan Bangladesh so it
looked like you know you're really
moving along and we're only six years
into the program at this point but that
area
in India Pakistan Bangladesh you're
really dealing with a population at that
time of something around 700 million
people and that was the program was not
working we really were not making
progress and we didn't really know what
to do
and we found that people in India and
the subcontinent really move around a
lot more than we'd ever imagined or we'd
encountered in Africa there are roads
there are the jitney buses which you can
see here with a plenty quite a capacity
to move people around the whole families
would move from place to place so it was
much more population movement and we
were running behind we weren't getting
the outbreaks fast enough before it was
moving on this is a train going north
out of Calcutta
you can see the air-conditioned
compartment on the top and we as we
discovered very few tickets were
collected and in fact one that we did
check on there was just one ticket sold
and that was our whi adviser who bought
the ticket so it was it was really a lot
of movement so what did we do with the
population in India of 550 million we
decided in the spring of that year and
in fact June of 73 that what we needed
to do is try to search every village in
India in ten days time and we worked
with the Indian government Health
Department planning this so the idea was
to go to four different parts in the
village and so many tea shops and to ask
about cases and try to reach every
village in ten days the first results
came back and won one state of India
which was at that time I think they were
reporting 500 cases a week team found
10,000 cases and I must say the reports
came in to us and in Geneva I hold my
god 10,000 cases this was October
and the city smallpox season doesn't
really get started until late October
November when you really begin to get it
spread and things look pretty grim but
then that the the staff got organized in
this and said let's go to every house
not every village and so they set up a
program to visit every house in India in
ten days time and you say yeah I know
you know they went to all the houses but
we had quality control and the quality
control team went afterwards and if they
didn't get 90% of the houses they had to
send go back and redo the whole search
again and so we had a pretty good idea
that we were really getting cases and
they were beginning to get contained
spring of 74 we thought of the
january/february I remember discussing
it at the time we felt this is the worst
this is India if we can defeat smallpox
in India we're gonna be able to do it
the rest of the world and we were really
elated at that point and then the roof
fell in
there was remember there were they've
the petrol crisis in the Middle East and
they wouldn't ship gasoline couldn't get
back gasoline for the cars and the
railroads fell on strike and the
airlines went on strike and then the
health staff was threatening to go on
strike and about this time they had some
of the worst floods in in decades in the
whole area where the smallpox was
heaviest and there were refugees by the
thousands tens of thousands moving
around with smallpox and it really was
looked really grim and then May India
exploded the nuclear device we figured
there isn't too much more that could
happen but this turned out to be the
real breaking point because there are a
huge number of international staff
reporters witnessing this event and here
in India are the head
lines nuclear device being detonated and
smallpox in India its highest level in
20 years two-thirds or whatever it was
of all cases in the world or in India
and this did not go well with a prime
minister mrs. Gandhi was very unhappy
and we got a lot of help suddenly from
India the authorities and that really
turned was really the pivotal challenge
at that time we began to focus on we're
not doing vaccinations we don't care how
many vaccinations we have what we're
really looking at our cases so that the
target is zero zero cases and it's
strange that strange that maybe I wound
up at a dinner sitting next to a panda
named ax Charlie Schultz and what do you
say to Charlie Schultz I didn't really
you know what you make conversation and
I said I bet Snoopy hasn't been
vaccinated with this he grabbed a sheet
of paper off there and started sketching
madly and he handed it to me it's
smallpox target zero but he says he
wants you to know he's behind you so
that was that's his story of Snoopy and
smallpox target zero an Indian
Independence Day the Prime Minister and
a saluted India on its 28th anniversary
of freedom and this is the big event I
mean the major holiday in India is the
Independence Day on August 15 and she
makes her speech from the Red Fort and I
would say they it was at this moment
that to me was one of the great touching
moment something that really I'm still
emotional about when she announced that
India was free from smallpox for the
first time in written history at that
point I really began to see something of
a meaning here which I just had not
grasped before it was a very moving time
for all of us that left is only Ethiopia
it's country twice the size of Texas so
it's not as small as it may look it's
quite large largely Highland the health
facilities service serve whereas at that
time serving about five percent of the
population and travel by the staff was
largely by donkey and on foot yeah you
could only go so far and drop people off
and they would head off across country
and be picked up a week or two later
hunting for cases and vaccinating well
at 1974 as India is getting free the
Emperor Haile Selassie was assassinated
there was a Marxist takeover virtually
all of the foreign people from the
embassies were evacuated there were
three different civil wars broke out and
no there were really no foreign staff
were allowed outside of in Addis Ababa
the capital by the government except for
our smallpox people and they kept going
through this they wound up on we had
nine different occasions we had the team
kidnapped and they'd turn up eight ten
twelve days later they were being picked
up by Somali guerrillas and taken into a
Mogadishu we had the we had two
helicopters that were leased for us by
the US and we were using those to get
people around they got they captured a
helicopter and we had a ransom note to
free up the helicopter while they were
negotiating this the pilot Canadian
pilot was doing this and he vaccinated a
whole rebels when they picked him up
they were all acts new so
it finally came to an end Somalia got
infected
just as Ethiopia is finishing up we ran
on more than a thousand cases in Somalia
it was a desperate effort to finish up
Somalia before the Hajj began and
pilgrims began moving through Somalia
into Mecca but this was the last case at
a Lima lon 26th of October 1977 so we
missed our ten-year time timeframe our
goal which still annoys me is it's 9
months and 26 days over and the Somalis
had not been so difficult in hiding
cases we would have made the ten-year
goal but we didn't but that is not the
end and this is let me summarize very
briefly what came from this was the
launch of what some are now calling the
beginning of the vaccine era when we
began with smallpox and trying to reach
everybody in throughout the country 1967
there was no vaccine and no country in
the developing world that was trying to
reach everybody in the country with a
vaccine of any sort so that in looking
at equity and health services for El
this was the first effort to do this
what we were so surprised when we were
working in Africa was that the African
vaccinators were vaccinating an average
500 people today on average so you had a
team of four they were doing 2,000
vaccinations a day and what this really
was the result of was a pattern of
working with village leaders and getting
support and assistance and
schoolteachers and what have you and
wouldn't we saw this it seemed to me
that we really ought to be doing more
than that why aren't we giving DPT or
measles of polio these are being used in
the industrialized country
why can't will you do it there so we in
1970 convened w-h-o meeting and brought
this up and it was discussed and finally
it was decided that that there would
recommend a massive program well let's
say vaccinations so that all children
got at least smallpox DPT measles polio
and so that was passed them 1974 by the
World Health Assembly is a objective and
became the expanded program and
immunization which I could kick myself
today because we did this meeting and
that was the goal and we could have done
something war on disease or something in
our vaccine war its disease but instead
we got this sort of bland kind of that's
what's known as today but epi so it
UNICEF took this up as a high priority
rotary volunteered to raise a hundred
million dollars for polio vaccine
they've since raised something around
700 million I think the target was 1990
to reach 80 percent coverage for
children throughout the world and
substantially that was achieved and it's
going on from there and there are other
programs in place I just will show you
this brief bit about the Americas the
program actually got started in 1975 and
by 1980 the coverage is running about
50% for DPT measles and polio by
nineteen by 2000 they're up to 90% with
those three they've introduced hepatitis
B and H influenza and now we're running
pretty close to 90% throughout the
Americas and these are almost other
countries in the Americas with an
exception of Haiti and and Bolivia which
they like
and that's been a problem in the course
of this that 1985 the head of the chief
adviser there with WH or chief advisors
serda quadros recommended that we
undertake in the Americas to under to
get rid of polio in 1985 and that was
agreed with a five-year goal set in 1991
the last case occurred the Caribbean
countries expressed very they were very
unhappy
why were they unhappy well they didn't
have anything to eradicate because he
didn't have polio so they wanted to
eradicate something so they wanted to
eradicate measles well I was chairing
the Advisory Committee at this time I
said wasn't too enthusiastic it a lot
more problem to getting rid of measles
then with smallpox but never mind it was
supported they went ahead and did it the
last case of condemning measles or let's
say continuing measly except for
importation x' occurred in 2002 the next
step though they were giving measles and
rubella that german measles vaccine at
the same time let's combine vaccine so
he decided let's get rid of rubella
because it causes a lot of malformations
mothers have the rubella well this gives
another problem because rubella didn't
spread so rapidly and it can keep going
in an adult population so they set out
to vaccinate women up to age 40 and it
didn't stop it so then they decided to
have to buy vaccinate men update 40 as
well there's nothing more difficult than
vaccinating adults that just really are
not very cooperative but in nineteen
2008 was the last rubella case in the
Americas and the Kijana congenital
rubella syndrome which was such a
problem is no more there are no more
cases in occurring so this is a an
overview of the world these are w-h-o
numbers the lower figure the lower
curb is the one to look at this is polio
beginning 1980 and they actually
estimate dur about 350,000 you can look
at measles and this is what's happened
in global measles coverage and many
people just don't realize what has
happened and there are many changes that
have occurred and you can see the
numbers of cases here on measles are way
down and deaths are way off throughout
most of the countries with some very few
exceptions but that's getting a more of
a push so I think there's some important
lessons from all of this and it's not
what do we eradicate next but to say
that vaccines are clearly a very
valuable intervention for health and the
World Bank study which was done in the
1980s said that this is the best cost
benefit medical intervention available I
think the on our management side this
idea of having disease reports and doing
this regularly is important in polio
this was not pursued for 12 years after
the global eradication began and so it's
begun after around 2000 really pushing
to get reports in in a way you're trying
to get responsibility you're trying to
get flexibility you're trying to get
health staff the meat village elders the
field staff involved in a way that it's
not cannot be top-down you've really got
to it takes time but you've got to build
with the support and ideas that the
people have is theirs
often many different thoughts about how
to proceed that can come in and then it
was amazing to see that way political
differences disappeared with US and
Russia working together and we did very
closely so from the book this is the
sort of concluding bit to say that we
are only beginning to realize that
potential of public health and is a
field begging for fresh resourceful
ideas and a new generation of
professionals we're not constrained by
knowing what can't be done and that's
the way so many of our people working in
the field knew and they were told that
it couldn't be done and so they didn't
know they couldn't do it and so it was
with many who contributed so much to
making eradication a possibility
so dr. Anderson is yes is willing to to
answer some questions and what we would
ask is that is there a microphone for no
okay
well try it if you could and asking your
question if you could speak up because
we're recording this on the web and some
people are watching even now so try to
enunciate so I see a few hands let me
begin with Chelsea and then I'm just
gonna work my way back but variably
around five to ten percent of the people
would begin bleeding during the first
week and there are no survivors and then
there was a flat smallpox in which they
don't didn't have those little lesions
they were just like a like a skin over
it and then if you touch the skin
actually it's separated from and it was
just a horrible thing and so these
people died there was absolutely nothing
you could do for them no no no so no
survivors of the flat smallpox either it
was a hideous disease I could tell you
from going through a ward with smallpox
well that's something
just speak up if you could
well there's a Pharisee giving and
controversy it's been going on and that
is at the end of the smoke during the
smallpox program for the end we asked
countries that had smallpox specimens in
their labs to put them send them to one
of two collaborating laboratories Moscow
and Atlanta and by 1980 they were pretty
well we were down to two laboratories
and those are the only two other
countries designed a piece of paper that
in 1980 that they had checked and they
had no less of specimens in their
laboratories 1985 there was a an expert
committee on smallpox for w-h-o and
looking at a number of things one of
them was what should we destroy the
remaining smallpox virus is there a
chance that it could escape why not just
destroy it so over the next 10 years
actually the committee met on a year a
year to year basis one of the things we
were concerned about was to preserve
genetic information and so a library of
fragments of smallpox were created sub
different strains then the virus was
sequenced so you had a real definitive
map of not one but several strains then
the committee then wrote to mint
principle international international
and National microbiological societies
and said this is under consideration
about destroying the virus and we had
report or we had written reports from
five of the major microbiological
societies who said we agree the virus
should be destroyed in nineteen and year
1990 yes I'm trying to think here it was
a Louis souland and 2000 our 1990
Secretary of Health and Human Services
he announced
the assembly that the US would destroy
its stock of smallpox virus as soon as
it was sequenced that was accomplished
four years later that he talked with his
Russian colleagues and they agreed so in
1996 the committee was we felt we were
finished 1995 we felt we were finished
we wrought up the report and sent it to
the Director General the u.s. looked at
the report and decided they didn't want
to see it destroyed so it has been
before the World Health Assembly in 1996
it went to the World Health Assembly and
it was finally agreed because of the US
and Soviet Union now Russia objecting
that they wanted to do more research so
I said all right take three more years
than three more years and then three
more years there's a lot of anger in a
lot of developing countries about why
are we not destroying it what is the US
and Russia up to anyway why do you want
to keep it so this has been argued very
heatedly it was a major discussion at
the World Health Assembly this year and
went on for several days and they
finally decided that they would defer
further discussion for another three
years so this is where we are and I
think my own feeling is we ought to
destroy the virus there's no question we
should destroy it and there are all
sorts of objections being raised but
then let me just leave it there as
somebody said it's not scientific it's
political now
in this state in this day and age of the
AIDS with the bifurcated needle
technique still be used if smallpox is
still around even though you can
sterilize it there could be cases where
it wouldn't be properly sterilized so
then we this be no longer a valid
technique for smallpox treatment well I
think at this point there's a feeling
that one should never have an instrument
the needle of to be reused at all no
matter how you sterilize it so that this
has been the what has been the the tenor
of what what we should be doing if we're
putting up a stockpile we should have a
needle for every vaccinations going to
be done but the difference between this
and an ordinary needle an ordinary
needle you have a hollow bore and trying
to sterilize the needle thoroughly and
make sure nothing is there is more
difficult here you don't have the hollow
bore and the likelihood of transferring
something is pretty minimal so that I
think from all the lab study studies
there's really one would not need to do
it but I think as a principal the
decision has been made that if we do
vaccination we'll do it each one with a
separate needle so however if we're back
against the wall and we've got vaccine
if we don't have enough needles I'm
going to be out there boiling needles
I'll tell you that
on a sort of related note do you think
that in today's political current and
views about public health do you think
that this same campaign could have been
done again in 2010 2011 you're basically
saying suppose we started with smallpox
eradication today could we do it yeah
you know I've thought a lot about it I'm
not sure I know to tell you the truth I
think it would be vastly easier because
of communication and you got cell phones
and you've got internet my goodness that
what you could do in the communication
is marvelous on the other hand I think
there are there's certainly more in the
way of large-scale civil disorder then I
think we were seeing although we did see
quite a bit during a smallpox program
there's it's a bit different and I
really just don't know it's right now
there's the bureaucracy is much more
elaborate than it used to be and it's
very hard to cut through red tape much
harder than it was when we were out
there and working on it so it gets more
complicated getting from here to there
which makes a lot of decisions more
difficult than we had so I just I really
don't know I would only say this that
2001 came and I was brought back into
working in Washington and we had at the
time we looked at it where there was
intelligence which suggested that there
could be a second event and it would be
biological and we assumed for other
reasons it would be smallpox or and
and we checked with CDC to say okay
tomorrow we discover we got a smallpox
outbreak how much vaccine have we got at
that time they could put 90,000 doses in
the field not enough really to do much
of anything in our sole supply then as
the vaccine some of this material had
been stored since 1978 came around and
then we came up to 15 million doses but
my goodness if you had a smallpox
outbreak and you want a lot of people
vaccinated a lot of people demanding
vaccinations 15 million isn't going very
far we talked with people before 9/11
for other reasons to say how long would
it take to produce more vaccine because
by the time vaccine vaccination stopped
everywhere and there is no smallpox
vaccine producer and we thought were
confronted with that and what to do
so we talked with some of the very key
people and said look if we need that
vaccine and we cut every corner how long
would it take to get us its a vaccine
and after much discussion we finally
came up with a figure five years so I
can say there were some very hairy
moments back in 2001 which are not
really described however we got an
extraordinary person who former Major
General from the military who joined us
and we were all pretty dumbfounded
because within we cut red tape like it
has never been cut before and we had and
we were instead of finishing one study
to know what to do in the next wound we
were anticipating what would be starting
the next study so overlapping and we had
we had
and 24 months with 200 million doses and
could we have done it because at that
time it was urgent and we could move
very quickly and a lot of people were
working very closely together and we had
it was being produced in Austria for
example there were problems of the
Department of Commerce about bringing it
in without special licensing and a whole
lot of things that went with it
so I remember the meeting very well and
I said to the man from commerce I said
would it help if my secretary called
your secretary he said that will not be
necessary it will be done but that that
was a sort of lever you had which I I
don't know whether you would have that
same sort of feeling if we were real and
a real emergency now what could we do in
stopping smallpox I almost feel like we
probably could stop it but it would take
special measures
so over the course of you of your talk
you mentioned a couple of properties
that are specific to the smallpox virus
and to infection like there's the
evidence of the vaccine also obviously
evidence of the infection there's like
slower spread than you had expected and
with other infectious diseases there was
a cheap vaccine and vaccination
techniques so given all of these things
would you say that the tactics that you
used to stop the spread of smallpox then
would work
combating certain evil pathogens that
around today and if so why are there a
very good question and I think the fact
is that we could tell where every case
was and could draw build a ring of
vaccination around an immune immunity so
it wouldn't spread with a real advantage
but I think at this time you can look to
polio and for every paralytic case you
probably get 200 infections without
symptoms or very minor symptoms so that
it's very hard to know where the polio
is so you have to use some different
strategy and that that sort of strategy
we have the smallpox really it worked to
a degree with measles in Latin America
but only to a degree it spread so
rapidly that the small pocket was
spreading slowly measles spreads very
rapidly much more than smallpox does but
it still was very helpful
so in polio it's not been it's not would
not work very well but I think the big
problem we have with polio and I felt at
the beginning we needed a much more
potent vaccine polio you really in the
developing countries you got any of six
eight doses of oral polio vaccine to get
a coverage or get a take and it is not
heat stable so you've got to keep it
cold right out to the periphery and I
think I at the time 1988 when we first
got into this I felt we would not
succeed
without a better vaccine and that I was
I was all in favor of pushing very hard
to get the vaccine first and then begin
the eradication but it's not what
happened
what extent do you think that the
eradication of smallpox has led to the
has led to some organizations today or
foundations sitting the goal of
eradicating malaria
even though the diseases are very
different do you think that those
foundations really believe that because
we're a decay to smallpox that that's
realistic goal for malaria if we had a
vaccine is a really difficult question
because indeed malaria has been
pronounced the objective I think of the
Gates Foundation and they feel that it
can be done and I think then others I
think
w-h-o has endorsed this the question
when and the problem is that there is
not at this time a malaria vaccine which
could be used there is a malaria vaccine
very reported just within the last year
that does protect but it's very
difficult to produce it so there's a lot
of money going into producing a vaccine
but there are some other things that
have happened the use of bed nets of
putting distributing bed nets have been
dramatically effective in a number of
countries is dropped death rates by 50%
and people maybe are sleeping into the
bed nets if you don't want to be bitten
by bugs but it's also preventing spread
of malaria so that that makes a big
difference
you've got the drugs that you could use
to treat malaria and there are
diagnostic methods that are developing
so that you could do them much more
rapidly quickly and give drugs I think
that will help
I think the bed nets are helped and I
think insecticide will also help but
when push comes to shove I think the
ultimate test is going to be do we have
a vaccine and the reason is if you've
got back
Sene then the immune the you've got the
antibodies in the individual and you can
go through a whole area and can make
them immune if you're gonna treat all
smaller malaria cases you've got to have
a lot of people out there detecting
cases getting them reported and so forth
and so the bed nets
it's a compliance issue and that could
be better but isn't it gonna really do
it well mosquitoes are biting outside of
the time that you're under the down to
the bed net so I think there are several
ways I think there's a multi-pronged
attack and I I think we get a malaria
vaccine which I hope we can then I think
the malaria eradication we were is
realistic
I think they now talking I think that
many that people talk about 30-40 years
maybe necessary before we get there but
that's not bad to have the goal out here
because I think what it's saying is
let's look at the strategy of how best
to address the disease and but let's
it's far enough out so it could we could
take time develop a vaccine we're not
going to do something in a hurry which
is going to be totally inadequate
I had a question about with the malaria
prevention it seems like within Botswana
in other countries they've been able to
eradicate sleeping sickness via
cancelling out the vector through the
Teti fly why is malaria so different why
do they use bed nets why do they use so
many other policies when if they were to
go for the vector that would be the true
heart of the eradication well I think
with malaria
the difficulty is trying to get with any
of the vector borne diseases is trying
to do away with a vector which is very
difficult and vectors seem to have a
capacity to mutate and change and become
resistant and become a difficult to
escape whatever you're trying to apply
it's also difficult because you've
really got vectors multiplying in all
sorts of different places and trying to
apply this widely let's say doing
something about vectors very widely it
is really very difficult very expensive
it's really one of the problems so that
III think in all cases that the vector
control is important and I think to be
pursued it's a question of how far can
you get with it and at what cost and so
much of what we're driven by is cost for
developing countries is this is at the
moment we're looking at the question of
a vaccine which cost 50 cents a person
and this is really felt to be breakpoint
but if it's any more than 50 cents per
person you're just not going to be able
to either get the donor support for long
periods or they're gonna be able to
afford it in the country so it's there's
some very difficult problems here and
here that I think some very constructive
things are being done in support gates
and others NIH
courting vaccine production in other
countries many countries India's doing
quite a good job yeah Brazil's got a
very big operation going China and so
they're they're able to turn it out a
number these countries much less
expensively to look at ways that you
could make them more stable a number of
things coming along there and to figure
out how to use fewer doses of vaccine
with adjuvants that you can add or
giving it intradermally another approach
and to figure out ways to give it in a
different way I think one of the
exciting pieces is a little patch that
you couldn't micro needles on it very
tiny and you could apply it and within
five minutes the antigen is transferred
and produces antibody which is
equivalent to what they're getting when
they're given interim into the
subcutaneously
so that this is beginning I it's only
beginning part but it's demonstrated
proof of principle is there and now
could you produce some rapidly at a
large scale and and I think there's a
couple of laboratories have some ideas
on this they actually are producing
something that look like a very heat
stable and this would make a big
difference if you just put on a patch a
little something about that big and as
long as it's got about five minutes its
contact that point you can throw them
away so these are some devices and also
doing things by mouth of course this
would be a big advantage but that's also
been difficult but at least people are
working on them right now and a lot of
this with the developing countries in
mind we can use syringes and needles but
they think they're expensive when you're
getting into big numbers and better if
you can do it another way I'm encouraged
you